cher journal quand distancie mais il
peut nous faire de vrais coups de [ __ ]
l'armée des états unis d'amérique
attaque aujourd'hui l'ensemble de
l'alizé compagnie quoi ai-je bien fait
moi bordel on a tous superficie non on
va pas se faire fusiller lieutenant est
question de temps avant que le fessier
et ans à 4 semaines
un physicien allemand a disparu dans de
son extradition les rapports indiquent
qu'adolf hitler le forcerait à mettre au
point une arme de destruction massive
pour y arrêter dans le dos pour quitter
cette année jamais sauvé la vie hélas
après bach c'est la baisse de ma femme
qui ne cache pas que l'alizé de retour
dans la place ses gardes et tout va
redevenir comme avant
c'est une histoire de libération c'est
une histoire de vengeance ans je suis
entré sont conservés et fabriqué pour
faire de l'année infection va se passer
au poids de corps d'un vote puis
l'objection
voir chez leur maman
boulehya les connards
qui par les bills